hey everybody welcome to led live this
is actually going to be
a little different of a show we thought
about we wanted to start looking at some
trailers every once in a while we
thought about doing like a
trailer thursday or something like that
but it just depends it might not be an
every week thing but it's something that
we wanted to do and today's wednesday
anyway but
i wanted to jump in on this because a
friend of mine had been
asking me hey have you guys looked at
mortal kombat yet and i was like man
that thing is
huge there's like the game the first
game came out in like 1993
yeah on super nintendo and and now i
know there's at least 11 games
not including sub games like uh sub-zero
mythologies and all this but
so it's a huge franchise a huge saga
but now there's a movie coming out
called
mortal kombat i don't even know the
title of it but it's coming out in
2021 and there's one trailer
but we're gonna we're gonna look at that
we're gonna react to it and we're going
to look at it through the lens of the
bible i think there's a lot of
revelation type language in the movie
we've seen this over and over and over
we continue to see
movies that always have these same
attributes right it's always like the
end of the world
the villain is always like there you go
villains always like christ and they
flip it upside down so that
you as a viewer you obviously don't most
normal people don't want the villain to
win
so it's just kind of psychologically
messing with you to be like yeah
go hero but he shares a lot of con
attributes like that like satan it's not
the first movie they made they made one
like
what 15 20 years ago yeah oh longer than
that
yeah i mean when i was a kid they came
at one yeah there was a lot of
controversy over the video game
did you guys ever play the video game
yeah yeah i love it yeah i remember
playing the video game
like it was like all the parents were up
in arms like oh
you know how can kids play this kind of
violent video game that was like the
first
game that introduced fatality is like
ripping people apart
um scorpions and it was really the first
game that came to like a home console
that just was filled with
gorn violence and so on that alone i
would say no christian needs to be
watching this movie
it's it's violent it's all about murder
it's satanic i mean you just look at the
levels and everything
and actually the game saga is full of i
was looking to a little bit there's
there's different worlds or realms and
they even have a heaven and hell and
eden they have all these biblical
languages you know
um but i wanted to start this off by
saying
if you were just imagine you guys okay
i'm i'm coming to present you guys a
book that i just wrote this is
this is just uh for illustration right
here all right you guys are
christian books incorporated and i'm
saying hey i got this really cool book
that i wrote
it's based off of revelation it's going
to be like a christian
fiction book and here's basically the
the trailer for the book
a warrior woman is telling the hero
darkness the hero's name is darkness so
a woman warriors
is telling the hero darkness our target
energy
enemy tore through us in seconds he has
super human
abilities so they're they're fighting
against someone with superhero
abilities superhuman abilities she
notices a marking on his
chest and says you are one of the chosen
you have been marked by the dragon she
explains
that cultures all over the world
throughout history have been planning
for a great battle it's a battle of
mortals versus the one with superhuman
abilities
the chosen mortals unite and say
the fate of earth is in our hands
the hero says no matter how many of my
people you've put in the ground
we will not fail and then finally the
super villain
is finally revealed and says i am
wow what do you guys think about this
movie i hear a lot of revelation
language in there well we will you guys
publish my book and if not will you tell
me theologically why
why not like look at can you guys see
these
yeah things here yeah so yes i i would
be very against this kind of thing
because i
understand uh you know from a biblical
perspective what that end of the world
scenario is going to play out like and
so you know i think that this is
basically fighting against
against god calling a super villain
someone that says
i am that's that's well let's see what's
god's name let's take it like one line
at a time so
a warrior woman's telling a hero named
darkness
our target enemy tore through us in
seconds and he has super human abilities
what do you
what what would you summarize that as as
a
parable of
you're telling a warrior woman no a
warrior woman is talking to the hero
whose name is darkness
and she's she's talking about the
villain and she's saying he tore through
us
in seconds he has super human abilities
i suppose that if you're if you're yeah
if you're
where are you coming from this first of
all this is biblical language
yeah biblical language so you're using
the book of revelation to kind of
illustrate something so that
so the woman would be like an
illustration for the church
wow you're going deeper i wasn't even
thinking about the woman is just a
generic person but
yeah what do you think about this
villain who's
has super human abilities so then she
notices that he has a marking
on his chest and she says you are one of
the chosen you've been marked by the
dragon
like a mark is a bad thing no this is
the
thing about the book of revelation and
that's why i think people easily get
confused is
you know you're saying well the the the
villain has superhuman abilities well
on both sides they have superhuman
abilities satan does
and so does christ the hero's name is
darkness sure yeah
yeah aside from that they both have
superhuman abilities and then you get to
the point where it's like but you've
been marked
by the dragon well you know just like
satan always has a counterfeit
right and so in revelation everybody
gets marked yes everybody
that's true yeah it doesn't matter who
you are everybody's getting marked
yeah so it's it's the distinction of
what it is so being marked by the dragon
well what does that sound like that
sounds like the beast power right yeah
who's the dragon
that's what the bible in revelation
defines as god's enemies calls it the
dragon
yes you know and later on it
specifically says satan
right so
you know there's there's these
similarities because satan always
counterfeits what that christ is doing
it's like
you know the beast has horns well so
does the lamb
in revelation it has horns as well you
know
and the beast receives a deadly wound
well
so does the lamb it says it was you know
it was the lamb that was slain
so there's there's all these
counterfeits going on and so from
from a surface level perspective you
watch and it's like oh yeah that's the
bad guy that's like satan and da
da da da and you go through everything
because you're not thinking about it
because it sounds so
similar right right it's when you
start to okay pause let's think about
this
what do these things mean are they
as they appear right or are they
slightly
differently right or slightly different
and this is one of those cases where
it's slightly different you have to pay
attention to the distinctions so
yeah they're pointing all at they're
they're hitting it all the right a hot
button spots
but you have to think about what those
things uh represent
in in the bible the dragon's never the
good exactly never the good
exactly so then she explains that
cultures
all over the world throughout history
have been planning for a great battle
scotty has
a verse on his computer here revelation
16 verse 14 says for they are the
spirits of devil's working miracles that
go forth
unto the kings of the earth and the
whole world
to gather them to the battle of the
great day of god almighty oh wait
it said they're all over the world
cultures all over the world throughout
history i've been planning for a great
battle right so it sounds like
this book that i'm writing is about uh
is it the is it a is it about the lost
or is it about the righteous
who are going to battle
the lost yeah the lost are the ones who
are battling the lost are the ones who
are marked by the dragon
and the lost are the ones who are saying
hey our enemy
is the has super human abilities because
they're going to make war with them
satan's the one that always brings the
war yeah so listen to a little further
on
in revelation um this is revelation 20
verse 7
it says when the thousand years are
expired satan shall be loosed from his
prison and shall go out to deceive the
nations which are in the four quarters
of the earth
gog and magog gathered themselves
together to battle the number of whom is
the sand of the sea and they went up on
the breadth of the earth and encompassed
the camp of the saints
about that beloved city and then fire
came down from god
out of heaven and devoured them so
wow so it's kind of the same thing for
the superhero just like last week we did
uh you know the uh justice league
yeah kind of like batman is getting all
those
super uh super heroes you know to get
war
exactly i want people to see that we're
not just watching one thing and like
oh you're just trying to make something
out of it this is over and over and over
yeah every i mean
i i feel like hollywood's just running
out of ideas or they're trying to
brainwash you one or the other
yeah it's always the same thing i mean
if you think you know
how many stores have you seen with
something coming in the sky leaving
independence
um i mean you've got the whole
transformer series
you've got i mean these are all outside
threats coming to destroy
at marvel i mean uh justice league in
the end of the whole justice league is
all about
them to fight against this coming thing
in the sky
and here it is like you know the bible
talks about a day that there's going to
be a great
battle i mean that's kind of how how
it's stated in here as well
somebody said to look at job 41 because
it talks about lafayette leviathan
which is a a sea creature right
and uh leviathan in job 41 is this
it's essentially a sea dragon that's
what it is oh yeah right
and it's its scales are impenetrable you
know it's like
it man is no match for leviathan if you
read the
the chapter in job and you know god is
is describing this this creature
um that
it's so powerful you can't do anything
against it and it's really just a
it's a depiction of satan and again if
you look at revelation
you know the dragon comes out of the
what the scene
out of the sea right leviathan is is
essentially a picture of
satan it's in it's an old testament
portrayal of what you find in the new
testament
and one thing i i was looking at
recently and
maybe i should have done a trailer
reaction on this
but there's a new disney pixar film
called
luca right i was just showing you the
other day and there's a little boy
and his best friend is this
sea monster i was like oh
really the only time in the bible you
find a monster that comes out of the sea
is always a representation of satan but
he's the little boy's best friend
but he's a little boy and also raya and
if you look at the town
you know everybody is geared toward
getting rid of sea monsters by their
imagery you know like
this is a bad thing they don't want to
have anything to do with the sea
monsters
so it's kind of fascinating how they're
always working that in and yeah
right the same thing right the dragon
the dragon
you're into the it's the dragon right
and and now now this is not just a you
know i
want to be culturally sensitive
because you know dragons have been a
part of of the eastern
culture for a long time but i spent a
little a a a little bit of time in
taiwan
and i remember going and visiting some
places and just seeing dragons
everywhere and like in the in the um
burial places which are actually really
amazing to see there was just dragons on
everybody's like
uh tombstones and and you know and i
remember thinking like
isn't that kind of interesting when
we're all risen you know you're all
gonna see
what's going on everybody gets a chance
to see the
the the curtain is pulled back and it's
like you know are you being raised up
and are you
seeking the dragon were you seeking you
know the king
i want to give a thank you to anthony
thank you so much for your support
and to nicey nicey community
kennedy thank you so much for your
ministry i've been so blessed by your
ministry thank you so much guys i
appreciate your support
somebody said we're reaching because
it's in in chinese it's chinese culture
wow you guys are reaching so i want to
address that
a lot of people bring up the culture
aspect if if i go to
biloxi or louisiana their culture is
voodoo so
voodoo's okay right it's just our
culture what if i go somewhere else and
it's like well in our culture we
we uh we have sex with our own children
or something you know
it doesn't matter if it's culture if
it's wrong it's wrong i don't understand
why if you say well it's just culture
there's a lot of wicked things
in culture it doesn't make it right
right and i'm not trying to put down on
chinese culture or anything like that
i'm just really trying to say
isn't it interesting that you know the
bible speaks of the devil as a dragon
and it's like
there's been cultures along the world i
mean
you know you look at the history of the
hebrews when they were around there was
other cultures that were worshiping
and and had different things in their
culture but
really like paul says you know when you
pull back the layers they were
worshiping things that they didn't know
what they were
and they were actually demons also yeah
i'm not i'm not trying to make that line
of connection that like you know a
dragon just all of a sudden means the
demons i'm just saying
isn't it interesting that from a
christian perspective at the end
you know you have this imagery of this
dragon and it's like you know there's a
lot of dragon imagery
in in china he's called the dragon he's
called the serpent you look all around
the world mexico
mexico is in the in the aztec
empire it was the it's called uh
quetzalcoatl that is serpent with
uh winds um certainly isn't it
fascinating that it crosses so many
cultures though there's
dragon legends in
so many different cultures for a long
time like it's usually one of the
the more ancient of their legends is
this dragon creature
it's fascinating and let me tell you the
aztecs it was the one that
warriors they're like the best warriors
right like
but those guys they were more bloody
guys i mean they take the heart out you
know
or whatever but the thing is that the
serpent that was that one of the gods
yeah and then and then the new age
movement same thing you
you want to do a hand mudra and meditate
and and get the kundalini serpent to go
up to your crown chakra you know it's
always a serpent
a dragon and and another thing that i
want to just mention with this whole
dragon topic because
um you know as we've been discussing
this whole anime world
it's like you know i can't tell you how
many questions have come in or people's
comments saying
well you guys just don't understand it's
not like that in japan like christianity
doesn't mean the same in japan
yeah but it means that here so we're
watching that
here that's what it means to us you know
what i mean so
you know this is popular here so what if
we took
somebody some other culture sacred text
and completely twisted it around like
buddha's really an evil guy and all that
you know
like that wouldn't be that good yeah
now in in in this mortal kombat we're
talking about you know in the martial
arts
dragon is is the ultimate
that that's the creature that when
you're training you
always want to imitate because it has
the most power
you know as a dragon's tail strike you
know if i'm coming out like this it's
called a dragon's tail strike to strike
you
well you know you're using that power of
the dragon you make a punch with a
knuckle
your your middle finger and that's
called a dragon's head
and you're using that to strike pressure
points right
and so there's these different things
that are named after a dragon and
in other animals too but the shaolin
priests elisa ones and hunan
um in in tibet and in different places
it's different but
when you go to become a priest you um
you have to lift a cauldron at the end
of a hall
of like 100 or 108 wooden dummies or
something they're mechanically triggered
and
designed to essentially kill you so if
you make it out alive you're you're
pretty good but to get out of the
building there's a
there's a a cauldron you have to lift so
that the door
gets removed and it on one side is a
dragon which goes on
i think your right arm and the other
side is a tiger which goes on your left
arm
you know symbolizing this is the the the
power of the animals or creatures you
want to harness
so the dragon is very prominent in in
martial arts as
one of the creatures you want to imitate
others too but that's
that's the number one you know i wish i
could find the image of it um
eric wilson and the dragon revealed was
talking about how on the patches that
they'd have they'd have these patches
of a woman on a dragon in the sea right
it's like that's just a revolution i
never seen that was new to me when i
seen that i was like that's
so uh just to finish up with this thing
we have those chosen are saying the fate
of earth
is in our hands we know that christ is
coming to destroy the earth destroy the
wicked in the earth
he's removing the righteous and
destroying the wicked who are in the
earth
so if you are wanting to
save the earth from this destruction
then you're
part of satan's army who's doing that
boom yeah
michael show that show scotty's screen
there let me
let you see look at that so yeah so
here's an actual real
martial arts um you know patch
that you know that's really interesting
so below the japanese one
oh the japanese mm-hmm yeah
japanese wow that's amazing
um and so then let's go ahead and get
into the trailer
i i just did this little fictional thing
about
writing this book because i want it to
be i want to show you guys that
this isn't just like oh i'm just really
looking at this and i really want to
find something in here
i don't have to look for it it jumps out
at you when you read revelation when you
study the bible these things just jump
out at you like we talk about you
when you don't study the counterfeit to
see the counterfeit you study the word
of god
and then when you see these things they
just jump out at you and if i were to
write this
book and present it to a christian
publisher they would say why are you
writing this this is
you're making the enemy the hero you're
fighting against god
so let's let's just watch the trailer
you're going to see all these attributes
in this
tore through our trailer in seconds
superhuman abilities
different cultures all over the world
reference a great tournament
of champions
i think it's an invitation to fight for
something known
now we blurred that right
it's pretty good
new age
that's the villain
for the villain of the dragons oh
zero
you can clearly see if you put your
biblical glasses on this world that
they're presenting to you
you know that's the villain talking to
the the other side saying i don't care
how many people you've put into the
ground god has not put those people in
the ground
sin has put those people in the ground
you know what i mean
and and you know people can argue or not
you know whatever god's killed tons of
people in the bible
you know in the old testament but
ultimately that was judgment being
passed because of their sin
so the sin is what put them in the
ground so the fact that you see that
and and he's like you know we will not
fail i mean those are words from god
and i love it how so many so many movies
that we have analyzed on here
have this i am and people fight against
that they're like
yeah everyone says
in the new mortal kombat movie bada bing
bada boom
sub zero i want to bring this out too
this is a really interesting thing
because
really i mean i have not seen this i do
not know the backstory of this but i'm
just
i'm just guessing so you guys get a
chance to see how we sit down
and think and analyze content but
if sub-zero really is a depiction of god
or
jesus right like jesus is the one that
said i am
before he was jesus he was the you know
when he
when he showed up in the in the to moses
that was the character that
that came down to earth as jesus the one
that met
moses in the burning bush okay so he's
the one that said i am
now i find it very interesting that they
say sub-zero because what does the bible
actually say god is like god is
a consuming fact but he's also described
god in a very short sentence god is one
word perfect
now this is really interesting that if
this is an occult perspective
they flip it on its head and they go no
no he's the coldest individual out there
he ain't got no warmth to him you know
yeah and this guy's cold
also since we're talking about like
happiness everything has a reason right
every little detail this stuff has a
reason
sub-zero is what color blue we talked
about
the blue representing the law that's
right now look at this guy
this is the main hero this is the one
who's been marked chosen look at his
name
cole young now i was like i wonder what
coal means i'm thinking cold black coal
like you burn
but i looked it up that's what it means
i i was thinking
i'm you know i'm not thinking right it's
not going to really be cold it is it
says when you look up the name coal it
means black is cold
so the hero is black as coal and the
villain is
blue sub-zero who says i am
fighting against the law
like that's what i'm saying like for for
us to over and over point this out and
people to say
oh man you just you're picking something
out that doesn't mean anything
it was so predictable when he said i am
right then boom
i bet he's the villain i looked it up
then i looked up
well who is this coal guy
screen rant is saying that there's a lot
of uh
messages in the trailer that lead him to
be scorpion
now if you know anything about scorpion
he's from hell scorpion became a hill
spawn
reverent revenant residing in hell
no that's i mean see you
you can't flip that around we can't make
this up
i mean you can't all of a sudden be like
the hero of the story well he really
resides in hell but he's really a good
guy
really you know he's really the one
that's like like a christ type
see i i think you know nobody is going
to argue with you that
that movies is a powerful storytelling
format
right everybody's like hey this is one
of the most impactful things fact we
talked about this on the show the other
day
there's a reason why there is a
commercial during the super bowl sold
for five
million dollars for 30 seconds that
would be a really bad use of your money
if you think that
hey it did not work at all you know what
i mean yeah they're getting the
the profit back so what were you saying
about coal again
coal the name coal means black as coal
like
real coal you burn the hero the movie
that he's the he's the main character
i wouldn't i wouldn't say that because
cole a person's name is spelled c-o-l-e
yeah look it up i i did and it means
kale or cabbage
kayla cash yeah i don't know i don't
know
that's like a yeah maybe a different
site but yeah i'm pulling up cabbage on
a lot yeah i was gonna say because i
wasn't even gonna say that until i
looked it up and i was like p-o-a-l
yeah that would that would probably yeah
so i don't know that's why it's good to
have fact checkers on the show yes but
but
in the same way have you guys ever heard
of the lesser key of solomon
i have yeah so the lesser key of solomon
was actually a
list comprised i think it was in the
14th century or so
of the actual people that had
communication with demons so they
knew their names um and when you read
the list
and then even people like alistair
crowley he came back and he
met a bunch more demons and so he kind
of updated the list and
wrote a bunch of other people's names
those names
changed morphed kind of with similar
throughout different cultures and stuff
like that so
you know names can easily mean things
have double meanings and then even the
spelling can be swapped around and
that's very common in
in things like that so bale wasn't
always b-a-a-l
you know it kind of took different forms
yeah
i guess in my mind you know coal c-o-l-e
is how you would spell the name
coal c-o-a-l is how you would spell the
mineral
and i just not unlikely to cross those
people swarthy oh interesting
cold black charcoal so wikipedia says
differently
yeah so like i said i i was doubting i
was doubting that too and i thought that
was my first thought like
cole makes me think of black coal but i
was like surely not
but
so i mean that that's all i have for the
slides i wanted us to
you know respond looking at that through
the lens of the bible and i just think
it's
man it's not this cannot be just
coincidence over and over it can't be
something like
we're just crazy and we just make
something out of nothing and and i think
we we really need to illustrate
the idea that look you know the bible is
describing that the end
is near in fact you know pop culture is
once again you know putting this concept
out there over and over and over again
and so you know wherever you guys are
whatever you're into um you know you're
getting
a message that's very similar on both
sides of the fence that's true
one of them is really pushing you to war
against
you know that or roaring against morals
or
you know just really breaking you down
and and saying you know
do whatever you want follow your heart
there is no rules like
that's kind of one side of the argument
there's another side that's just saying
look the end
is near and be prepared and so
you know whatever you know side of the
fence you you are
standing on um you know we hope that
you'll just take it
seriously and look into what the bible
has to say
and and you know balance that against
what the world is saying because a lot
of times
there's two perspectives coming at you
but they're really discussing the same
thing
and so you know it's really easy to
dismiss oh whatever you guys are
christians and crazy and blah blah blah
but you know you know really look at
what the world is pushing out there
in the same way it's pushing what a lot
of christianity is talking about
as well so um both can't be right
uh you know one's one's gonna be a
counterfeit of the other one and
and i believe that um you will do well
if you stand on the
the source of truth the bible yeah amen
so get into that word
read revelation so you can understand
what keeps being pushed out here and
and you can catch those little catch
phrases you know like
when you watch a trailer we don't have
to watch these movies people say oh you
didn't watch the movie you're judging it
i am judging i'm making a a righteous
judgment on this do not watch this movie
it's
the hero is from hell and he's fighting
against the guys that i am and it may be
a coincidence but either way
this movie is violent and wicked and
i just wanted to show you that there is
a spiritual battle out there there
is a war for your mind for your soul and
we know according to the bible that
christ is going to return he's going to
bring destruction and and you're either
going to go up with him or you're going
to be left
to be destroyed with this fire and god's
people won't be marked with the dragon
that's going to get their power from the
dragon yeah i also want to like
just throw a bible verse out there
psalms 11 5
because obviously talking about this
kind of a
of a story is very violent in fact you
blurt out
some of the stuff because we can't even
really like show that kind of violence
in in good faith
listen to what psalms 11 5 says the lord
tests the righteous but his soul
hates the wicked and the one who loves
violence
you know there's there's very few times
that the bible will describe that god
actually hates something and because the
bible describes
yeah the bible the bible describes god
as love
and here we have an an example of god
saying look
i can't stand violence because of what
it does i mean it's destroying my people
you end somebody's life
they can no longer choose from that
point on they're done they're sealed
and i think that's why god really hates
violence so just based on this
alone i mean even if you don't believe
what we're saying
in a in a connection of revelation and
this and that
don't go watch this on just the violence
aspect alone
yeah if you go in the ending somebody's
life
you know when jesus was was in the
process of dying
what was he agonizing over he was
agonizing over the lost connection with
his father that he had from
eternity past and so i think what god
is what he you know hates about where
violence leads is
you lose that connection permanently you
know
and that's what he came to do is to
restore that connection back permanently
otherwise we wouldn't have it
you know god didn't create the human
race to watch us die
out and be nothing he created us
to be forever that's right you know
that's why ecclesiastes
says he's put eternity in our heart so
you know if if that's where violence
leads that's why god hates it
yeah yeah anybody have any last remarks
yes uh two things one is the i mean just
see the trailer
i mean i remember i used to play that
game when i was in middle school i mean
i think i spent a lot of money in that
that's worse than that you should play
i know i know i know but i i think i
spent a lot of money and those machines
you know bringing my
you know my coins and everything uh
and i was thinking you know back then i
mean like you were saying i mean the the
violence and all stuff
and i mean just to to memorize those
phrases you know come here
yeah all the stuff i mean but let me
tell you that was like 20 something
years
and right now i mean like we were
talking about violence i mean we don't
want
another bloody violence moving man i
mean
look at the world when you just turn the
tv on it's like can we just make
something like
love your family man i mean to carry
your kids and you
you know or your your self-esteem or
something like that you know something
to help the world
a better place i mean i'm not against
that thing you know
but it's like with this movie i mean
think about this what if someone came up
to your daughter
and got into a fight with her and people
were yelling finish her
you know and rip her heart out and this
and that right that'd make you
pretty upset anyone anyone who's there
who has a family member and stuff if
somebody was doing that to your child
or your family member you'd be upset but
why don't we have that same
view towards just everyone why aren't we
just displaying the love of christ why
is this what's coming out of our society
and and i believe that there's there's a
stark difference between
those that follow this system of the
world and those that say you know what i
want to love my enemy i want to
love those that that hate us and spit on
us and make all these
terrible comments towards us we love you
guys thank you for showing up
and so you know this is this is where
the rubber meets the road
where's your christian character being
developed right now and i don't believe
that this is profitable
at all i don't know they blurted out you
couldn't see it but
i i'd seen the trailer when it came out
there's one part where sub-zero he
injured somebody
and then there was blood involved and
either took a piece of the body or the
blood and used that to inflict
further injury like he froze it and made
it a weapon
to continue using i mean that's just
like no feeling like you know
sadistic which is even more interesting
because you know like
god's you know life is in the blood yeah
there's a lot of interesting
life is in the blood and you're using
the blood to kill somebody yeah
yeah well we hope this was a good
trailer review if you guys
like this type of thing where we're
going to react or review trailers we see
that a lot of people like that
we're probably going to give you a
little bit of different uh review or
reaction than most other
channels out there but if you like it
let us know and we'll keep this thing up
but we pray that you guys were blessed
and that this was a warning and
hopefully you didn't need much of a
warning to stay away from this movie but
we'll see you guys this friday on led
live until then
we'll see you guys later so just like
the t-shirt says real eyes realize
real lives we realize it should we tell
them about our documentary on martial
arts
oh yeah i mean go ahead yeah right yeah
right so we have a documentary on the
martial arts that we made several years
ago
and um it's a two-part series the first
part you can actually find for free
on our youtube channel and can we put
share a link in the description below
yeah yeah yeah we'll put a dragon down
can we give him a discount sure we can
give him a discount yeah
okay we'll put a discount link in the
description below yeah
that way you guys can watch the whole
thing because part two is a really good
part
part one's a testimony it kind of shows
how
all this was revealed to eric wilson but
part two man it's just
mind-blowing and we have also in spanish
the drowned reveal
uh part one uh eric wilson
testimony is in spanish too so if you
have spanish friends
uh we're gonna put that link there and
share it sure the other thing i was
gonna say is you want to learn more
about the bible
we have bible studies and so we'll also
put that link in the description below
and you can study
and enroll in our bible school and learn
more
about what the bible teaches and what's
coming down the pipe in these last days
and thank you guys for those that
donated through the super chat
and patreon donors or anybody that's
watching that supported our ministry
over the years
not only with finances but with just
prayer or
encouragement or something like that you
guys this is the reason why we do what
we're doing
and uh we love you guys and we hope that
you're blessed by
all the things that you see coming out
of this ministry all right take care